MEET THE FOLKS I WAS JUST
HANGING WITH.
THANK YOU, HONEY.
THANK YOU, FOR THE INTRODUCTION.
YOUR FORBEARANCE IS COMMENDABLE.
I -- THIS HAS TO BE AN EMOTIONAL
MOMENT.
FOR YOU, THE FAMILY, THE
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR THE
PASSPORT INTO YOUR DISTRICT,
APPRECIATE IT.
AND I WANT TO ALSO THANK
EVERYONE HERE THAT TOOK THE TIME
TO BE HERE.
AND, YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE
THINGS, BACK IN THE 1900s,
DAWSON SPRINGS WAS A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE CAME TO BE HEALED,
BECAUSE OF THE MINERAL WATERS.
LITERALLY WAS THE PLACE YOU CAME
TO HEAL.
NOW, IT'S OUR TURN TO HELP THE
ENTIRE TOWN TO HEAL.
YOU KNOW, I GRANTED THE REQUEST
FOR THE FIRST EMERGENCY
DECLARATION AND MAJOR DISASTER
DECLARATION THE MOMENT I
RECEIVED IT, BECAUSE I GOT TO
KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S FATHER AND I
KNEW NOTHING WOULD COME, IT
WASN'T REAL, I MEAN IT, FOR
REAL.
Y
YESTERDAY I ALSO APPROVED
EMERGENCY DECLARATION FOR THE
STATE OF ILLINOIS AND TENNESSEE
AND INTENDED TO DO WHATEVER IT
TAKES, AS LONG AS IT TAKES, TO
SUPPORT YOUR STATE, LOCAL
LEADERS, AS YOU RECOVER AND
REBUILD, BECAUSE YOU WILL
RECOVER AND REBUILD.
YOU KNOW, THE SCOPE AND SCALE OF
THIS DESTRUCTION IS ALMOST
BEYOND BELIEF.
WHEN YOU LOOK AROUND HERE,
ALMOST JUST BEYOND BELIEF.
THESE TORNADOS DEVOURED
EVERYTHING IN THEIR PATH AND AS
I FLEW OVER HERE IN A HELICOPTER
YOU LOOK DOWN, SEE A HOUSE, 20
YARDS AWAY FROM A HOUSE, A HOUSE
DEVASTATED AND A HOUSE IN GOOD
SHAPE.
I MEAN TORNADOS ARE AND SUCH
DEVASTATING STORMS.
BACK WHERE I'M FROM, WE'RE USED
TO HURRICANES AND FLOODS AND
HIGHWATER BUT THESE TORNADOS ARE
JUST SOMETHING TOTALLY
DIFFERENT.
D
DEVOURED EVERYTHING IN THE PATH,
HOMES, BUSINESSES, HOUSES OF
WO
WORSHIP, DREAMS, LIVES, YOU SAID
WHAT, 74 FATALITIES NOW IN
KENTUCKY AND MAKING THIS ONE OF
THE DEADLIEST TORNADOS TO EVER
STRUCK THIS STATE.
ALMOST 14 PEOPLE CONFIRMED IN
OTHER STATES WITH DOZENS OF
PEOPLE STILL FEARFUL OF WHERE
THEY ARE.
I MET ONE, I DON'T HAVE
PERMISSION TO USE THEIR NAME BUT
I MET ONE COUPLE ON THE WAY UP
SAID THEY'RE STILL LOOKING FOR
FOUR OF THEIR FRIENDS.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY ARE.
THOIZ WHO HAVE LOST SOMEONE,
THERE'S NO WORDS FOR THE PAIN OF
LOSING SOMEONE.
A LOT OF US KNOW IT.
A LOT OF US UNDERSTAND IT,
ESPECIALLY AROUND THE HOLIDAYS,
WHEN EVERYTHING IS SUPPOSED TO
BE HAPPY AND JOIF JOYFUL, A LONE
AGO I GOT A CALL AROUND THE
HOLIDAY, I WAS YOUNG SENATOR,
NOT SWORN IN YET AND GOT A CALL
FROM A FIRST RESPONDER SAYING
THERE'S BEEN AN ACCIDENT,
TRACTOR TRAILER BROADSIDED MY
WIFE WITH A CHRISTMAS TREE ON
WIFE, THREE KIDS INSIDE, WIFE
AND DAUGHTER ARE DEAD.
BUT MY MOTHER, GOD, LOVE HER,
SAYS EVERYTHING TERRIBLE,
SOMETHING GOOD HAS TO HAPPEN, IT
CAN'T BE ALL BAD.
WE HAVE TO MAKE IT BETTER.
SO FOLKS, THOSE WHO'VE LOST
SOMEONE, KNOW, KNOW HOW TOUGH IT
IS AND YOU KNOW HOW TOUGH IT IS.
YOU KNOW, IN MAYFIELD JUST
HOURS BEFORE THE STORM, THE
GIBSON PHARMACY HAD BE FULL OF
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN WAITING
TO MEET SANTA.
NOW, IT'S COMPLETELY GONE.
AND SO MANY BUSINESSES VITAL TO
THE COMMUNITY SO DAMAGED AND
DESTROYE
DESTROYED AND YOUR TOWN AS WELL
BUT THERE'S A SAYING IN SMALL
TOWNS.
PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT IT WHEN YOU'RE
BORN AND CARE ABOUT IT WHEN YOU
DIE.
THEY KNOW ABOUT IT WHEN YOU'RE
BORN AND CARE ABOUT IT WHEN YOU
DIE.
WELL IN SO MANY PLACES,
DESTRUCTION WAS MET WITH
COMPASSION, NEIGHBORS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS RACING TO SAVE EACH
OTHER'S LIVES AND SUPPORT.
I ASK, I'M NOT JOKING, I ASKED
WHEN I GOT TO MAYFIELD WHAT WAS
THE FIRST THING MY FIRST
RESPONDERS, FEMA, WHAT THEY
HEARD AND SAID THEY WERE AMAZED.
ALL THEY HEARD WAS JUST PEOPLE
GOING OUT HELPING ONE ANOTHER.
EVERYBODY.
JUST STEPPING PUP IT'S
INCREDIBLE HOW YOU ALL STEP UP.
SO, FOLKS, YOU KNOW, THE FACT IS
I'LL MAKE SURE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STEPS UP AND MAKE
SURE WE DO EVERY SINGLE THING.
FOR YEARS AND YEARS AS U.S.
SENATOR AND VICE-PRESIDENT, WE
COME FROM DELAWARE WE HAD A LOT
OF SERIOUS STORMS.
HURRICANES, OCEANS RISING, WHOLE
RANGE OF THINGS, BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT?
IT ALWAYS TOOK A LONG TIME.
NO REASON IT SHOULD TAKE ANY
TIME.
WE HAVE THE WHERE WITH ALL TO
GET IT DONE AND WE'LL GET EVERY
SINGLE THING YOU NEED AND MAKE
SURE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES
WHAT'S NEEDED.
AT THE STATE'S REQUEST FOR FEMA
SEARCH AND RESCUE TEAMS WORKING
IN KENTUCKY RIGHT NOW.
FOR THOSE WITHOUT POWER, FEMA
ALREADY BROUGHT 61 GENERATORS,
ARMY CORE OF ENGINEERS HAS
TEMPORARY POWER INSTALL TEAMS
READY TO ASSIST IF NEEDED AND
PROVIDED CRITICAL SUPPLIES FOR A
LOT MORE TO COME.
144,000 LITERS OF DRINKING WATER
24,000 MEALS, JUST, 74,000.
AND LOOK, THOUSANDS OF COTTS AND
BLANKETS.
THERE ARE SEVEN SHELTERS OPEN IN
KENTUCKY WHICH ARE NOW TAKING
CARE OF 300 TOCCUPANTS BUT WILL
BE A LOT MORE.
WE WANT PEOPLE OUT OF THE
SHELTERS AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN
BECAUSE OF COVID AND ULTIMATELY,
PROVIDE SOME CERTAINTY FOR
PEOPLE.
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN RESPONDING
TO A LOT OF DISASTERS AND YOU
KWZ IT I
CAN SEE IT IN PEOPLES' FACE AND
SEE WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR IS
TO PUT THEIR HEAD DOWN ON A
PILLOW, CLOSE THEIR EYES, TAKE
AT THAT DEEP BREATH, GO TO SLEEP
AND MAKE SURE THE KIDS ARE OKAY.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
FOR RIGHT NOW BUT A LOT OF HARD
WORK WILL HAPPEN IN THE NEXT TWO
OR THREE MONTHS TO BRING IT ALL
THE WAY BACK.
SO FOLKS, GOV, I WANT TO PROVIDE
YOU THE CERTAINTY AS WELL.
I JUST APPROVED THE REQUEST THAT
I WASN'T SURE I HAD THE
AUTHORITY TO DO BUT TURNS OUT I
DO.
THE GOVERNMENT'S GOING TO COVER
100% OF THE COST THE FIRST 30
DAYS, CLEARING EVERYTHING, EVERY
SINGLE COST THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL TAKE CARE OF.
INCLUDES DEBRIS REMOVAL, COST OF
OVERTIME, EMERGENCY SERVICE
PERSONNEL AND SHELTER AND BY THE
WAY, I WANT TO THANK YOUR WIFE.
SHE STARTED A TOY DRIVE FOR THIS
PART OF THE STATE TO MAKE SURE,
HOW MANY -- COME HERE.
I'M TAKING CREDIT FOR SOMETHING
I HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH.
>> HOW CAN YOU?
>> TELL THEM WHAT YOU GOT SO
FAR.
>> WELL, AS OF THIS MORNING, WE
THINK THAT WE HAVE AROUND 20,000
GIFTS DONATED AND GOT THREE MORE
DAYS TO GO.
>> 20,000 GIFTS, NO KID'S GOING
TO GO TO SLEEP, WHEREVER THEY
GET TO SLEEP TONIGHT WITHOUT A
GIFT.
GOD, LOVE YOU.
NOW LOOK, WE ALSO NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THE PEOPLE WHO
SUFFERED MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL
INJURIES.
THE COST OF THIS SOMETIMES ARE
UNSEEN AND UNKNOWN.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE TALK ABOUT POST
TRAUMATIC STRESS ON THE BATTLE
FIELDS AS I TRAVEL THROUGH
AFGHANISTAN AND IRAQ WELL GUESS
WHAT, THERE'S A LOT OF POST
TRAUMATIC STRESS THAT COMES FROM
LYING IN YOUR HOUSE AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN THE ROOF BLOWS OVER AND
YOU WONDER IF YOUR KIDS ARE
AROUND.
I REALLY MEAN IT.
SO WITH THE SHOCK OF LOSING A
HOME AND BUSINESS, GRIEF OF
LOSING SOMEONE, IT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT BEFORE THE HOLIDAYS I
SAID, WE'LL MAKE SURE YOU HAVE
ALL THE HELP YOU NEED, INCLUDING
THE KIND OF MENTAL HELP THAT'S
NEEDED TO HELP PEOPLE THROUGH
DIFFICULT TIMES.
AND FOLKS, YOU KNOW, THE FEMA
HAS OPENED MOBILE DISASTER
RECOVERY CENTERS IN MAY FIELD
AND IN DAWSON SPRINGS.
AND IT HAS DISASTER SURVIVOR
ASSISTANCE TEAMS ON THE GROUND
HERE IN KENTUCKY, TO HELP PEOPLE
REGISTER FOR ASSISTANCE.
AS I SAID WHEN I TALKED TO THE
GOVERNOR, NOT ONLY GET YOU WHAT
YOU NEED, BUT MAKE SURE
EVERYTHING IS AVAILABLE BECAUSE
YOU DON'T ALWAYS KNOW ALL THAT
IS AVAILABLE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO.
AND FOLKS, YOU KNOW, IF YOU LIVE
IN INFECTED AREAS WHICH ALL OF
YOU ARE STANDING, WATCHING ME
DO, YOU VISIT DISASTER
ASSISTANCE.GOV, DISASTER
ASSISTANT.GOV OR CALL 1800621
FEMA, THAT'S 1800621 FEMA.
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAL, RECOVER,
REBUILD, BE STRONGER THAN
BEFORE, AND BUILD BACK BETTER
THAN IT WAS, AND WHEN I COME
BACK, I GOT ONE BEAUTIFUL LADY
AND HER HUSBAND PROMISE ME A
MEAL.
SHE'S APPARENTLY HEAD COOK SO
I'M COMING BACK FOR THE MEAL.
SO THANK YOU, THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND TO ALL FAMILIES
HERE, KEEP THE FAITH.
WE'RE GOING TO GET THIS DONE.
I PROMISE YOU.
THE GOVERNOR'S NOT WALKING AWAY,
YOUR JUDGE NOT WALKING AWAY,
CONGRESSMAN'S NOT WALKING AWAY,
NO ONE'S WALKING AWAY.
WE'RE IN THIS FOR THE LONG HAUL,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
NOT NOW -- WE DON'T NEED IT YET.
THERE HAS BEEN, BECAUSE OF
WEATHER DISASTERS, JUST THIS
YEAR, OVER $99 BILLION IN
LOSSES.
$99 BILLION IN LOSSES, AND AS I
FLEW OVER I WAS TELLING FOLKS
HERE.
AS I WAS OUT FOR THE GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA, IDAHO AND OTHER
STATES, AS YOU FLY OVER THOSE
TERRITORIES FOR THE BETTER PART
OF AN HOUR LOOKING DOWN, EVERY
SINGLE SOLITARY THING IS LEVELED
BECAUSE OF THE FIRES, NOTHING
THERE, THE FORESTS, THE HOMES,
THE BUSINESSES, AND GUESS WHAT?
SO MUCH AREA HAS BURNED THIS
YEAR, BECAUSE OF WEATHER AND
CLIMATE CHANGES, THAT IS LARGER
THAN THE ENTIRE STATE OF NEW
JERSEY.
THE ENTIRE STATE OF NEW JERSEY,
THAT'S HOW MUCH LAND HAS BEEN
BURNED TO THE GROUND.
SO WE GOT A